[Music]
[Music]
noah sanders here for the job interview
please take a seat mr weinstein we'll
see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
job interviews huh
never fun
okay
i get it stay focused
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a big laugh
oh no i didn't no you did it
[Laughter]
is a job interviewer the carol burnett
show you know what i mean
oh my god that is too rich
thanks so much for coming in adam of
course and you better stay away from
that chinese oh my god you got that
right
doing a number on my stomach
here's your fortune you're going to be
sick
[Laughter]
oh my gosh what an absolute delight it's
been great and can i tell you something
really quick
i don't even care if i get this job
because i know i've made a friend for
life
what a terrific attitude
what a great goddamn attitude yeah you
son of a gun
you know
what right quick before you leave i want
to give you something no sir i can't
take any more gifts this whole thing has
been a gift
my brother passed away
21 years ago
we were estranged
and he became ill
and he gave this to me
as a peace offering
and then one day when we were on the
ocean he fell overboard on a boat very
much like this one and died
i saw him struggling all the way as a
rip type just pulled him down
[ __ ] ocean
could you please accept this as a token
of my gratitude for you bringing joy
back into my life
under any other circumstance i would
refuse
but i will accept this gift today
because i know how much it means to you
so i will
thank you
oh i'm eating
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this guy how do you keep a straight face
all day
and she's sweet sweeter than five oh my
god god damn it i love your energy well
all right what can i say sir i am solar
powered
really you like you like that one huh
oh thanks so much adam terrific
best interview i've ever been a part of
in my entire life
okay who's next
you ready let's go chop chop here we go
come on let's go
okay
requesting permission just come on board
sir hi noah sanders name uh sorry to
hear about your brother maybe we can get
some chinese food after this all right
all right okay take it easy
jeez settle down turbo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
super train um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
supernova spanish
detroit
[Music]
disease
trees
[Music]
currency
[Music]
hey what the hell are we saying man i
got no idea man i'm just hungry and
talking about the galaxy and trains i
think they buying it though
[Applause]
thank yous for meeting me here yeah of
course you know he's glad we could set
aside our differences and avoid the war
here you know so
all right salute
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no
that's too much what are you doing we're
just having a nice little dinner here
all right well that's just disrespectful
oh no not his head he had good hair yeah
you're done you're already messing with
him
what are you doing now
this phone no no no don't go deleting
this contact he's not gonna know where
to answer it or not you're finished now
that's that's good look what you did now
we were in the middle of something today
and now whatever what's going on here
what are you
that's permanent that's a permanent
silly mustache oh now he looks like a a
sleeping musketeer that's adorable but
it's it's ridiculous he can't he can
hardly wash that off that's it whatever
where you going
what is
[Music]
that doesn't even make sense here that
doesn't even make sense
oh oh anthony oh that's hilarious but
save that for a slumber party all right
what are you no you're rearranging the
silverware that's just so mean that's
it's confusing it's confusing enough
what what the hell
hit me don't do oh well you know the
salad you get a little pepper so that's
good that's so that's that's not so bad
you finally did something constructive
what are you looking for what are you
you're putting the silverware back
that's good
that's good now he knows he can go from
outside to inside and that's oh
you put a little zhu in his head that's
good yeah [ __ ] oh no it actually looks
better than when he came in if he wasn't
unconscious he could go out on the town
so that's good that's good okay look
here you go all right white wipe off his
face yeah yeah yeah get the mustache
while you're at it because that's the
most embarrassing part oh he doesn't
look ridiculous anymore oh okay now
that's that's now you're helping
everybody that's good for everybody
everybody likes that nobody wants
lettuce on the floor
[Music]
all right we're done all right you
really turned this around at me there
he's all right and then you're garnet
all right all right he won't even know
what hit him he won't even know that any
oh no
no no no no anthony eddie i can see it
in your eyes i can see it in your eyes
you're going the other way now anthony
and he was going so well
well that's that's that's perverse
hearing me i don't even know what what's
that what's that what are you going to
do with that finger what are you oh yeah
i'm telling you vinnie no disrespect to
your daily departed grandmother but my
aunt makes it pasta forget about it
your van lives in this neighborhood
it seems kind of dangerous
what are you mcgruff the crime dog
come on we're late already
yeah you you say she lives in this house
here
what the [ __ ] the matter with you
vinny you're being rude let's go
not trying to be rude
the lights are off maybe we
let's come back later again she's
probably just taking a nap after the
huge meal she just made for us
go in
i don't have the key you should go in
first
she said she'd leave it open
vinnie stop being selective stroonz
and get in there
all right all right
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
away
[Music]
[Music]
surprise
[Music]